we're told that kyra works on a team of
13 total people
her manager is randomly selecting three
members from her team to represent the
company at a conference
what is the probability that kyra is
chosen for the conference
pause this video and see if you can have
a go at this before we work through this
together
all right now let's work through this
together so we want to figure out
this probability and so one way to think
about it is
what are the number of ways that kyrah
can be on a team or the number
of possible teams teams
with kyra and then
over the total number of possible teams
total number of
possible teams
and if this little hint gets you even
more inspired
if you weren't able to do it the first
time i encourage you to try to pause it
again
and then work through it all right now i
will continue
to continue so first let me do the
denominator here what are the total
possible number of teams some of y'all
might have found that a little bit
easier to figure out
well we know that we're choosing from 13
people and we're
picking three of them and we don't care
about order it's not like we're saying
someone's going to be president of the
team someone's going to be vice
president and someone's going to be
treasurer we just say there are three
people in the team
and so this is a situation where out of
13
we are choosing three people
now what are the total number of teams
possible teams that could have kyra
in it well one way to think about it is
if we know that kyra's on a team then
the possibilities are who's going to be
the other two people
on the team and who are the possible
candidates for the other two people
well if kyra is already on the team then
there's a possible
12 people to pick from so there's 12
people to choose from for those other
two slots
and so we're going to choose two and
once again we don't care about the order
with which we are choosing them
so once again it is going to be a
combination
and then we can just go ahead and
calculate each of these
combinations here what is 12 choose 2
well there's 12 possible people for that
first non-chira seat
and then there would be 11 people there
for that other non-chira spot
and of course it's a combination we
don't care what order we picked it in
and so there are two ways to get these
two people we could say two factorial
but that's just the same thing as two or
two times one
and then the denominator here for that
first spot
there's 13 people to pick from then in
that second spot there are 12
then in that third spot there are 11 and
then
once again we don't care about order
three factorial ways to arrange three
people so i could write
3 times 2 and for kicks i could write
1 right over here and then we can let's
go down here this is going to be equal
to
my numerator over here is going to be 6
times 11 and then my denominator
is going to be 12 divided by 6
right over here is 2. so it's going to
be 13
times 11 times 2
just to be clear i divided both the
denominator and this numerator over here
by 6 to get 2 right over there now
this cancels with that and then if we
divide the numerator and denominators
by 2 this is going to be 3 here this is
going to be 1.
and so we are left with a probability of
3 13 that kyra is chosen for the
conference